Now you can edit out any extraneous sounds like I have to clear my throat, not going to
stuff.
Okay.
All right.
So let's start.
If you would just introduce yourself.
This is a statement name on today's date in our location.
Okay.
My name is Kenneth Hedberg.
The date is September 9th, 2011.
Okay.
Ken, where were you born and where did you go?
I was born in Portland, Oregon, in February of the Second and 1920.
And you did you go to Portland?
Well, I actually know.
I spent my first six years of life there.
And then my father had a job that took him to Southern Oregon.
I grew up in Oregon, a Kusbe region, which is that time where we lived as called Marshfield.
And after that we moved to Hokkaido, Washington where I spent my years from age about 12 to 16.
We were upon we moved to Medford.
And I went to school, graduated from high school in Medford.
What were your various occupations?
Oh, well, my mother was a housewife during the war.
She worked at the Naval Station in Astoria.
My father was called, or was called a wholesale grocery salesman.
In those days, groceries were delivered by truck from a large warehouse to the retailers.
And my father would travel to these small retail stores, some of them in outlying rural areas.
And take their orders for groceries, which he would then write up on a farm in the late evening.
Early in the morning, take it to the warehouse and the orders would be filled.
And the trucks would then take these groceries out to the various stores that had ordered them.
That, of course, passed pretty quickly in the time of better communications.
So that business is faded now.
So that was disappeared, actually.
That was a job that would require some moving around the family.
Yeah, well, my father had a, actually know that he changed jobs.
He worked for a company called Mason Irman, which is now out of business.
And they had several stores warehouse in southern Oregon and Medford in Kuspe, and in Astoria.
And he worked in all of these places for that company as they move things around.
The, that kind of, well, these rural stores were, of course, separated wide intervals.
And they were grouped together into what my father called a route or a route.
And on a given day of the week, he would go in a certain, on a certain route, take him all day long.
And the next day would go on a different run in the third day and so on.
So it was a lot of driving and some of that over quite distance significant distances.
That's about as much as I company around the few of these drives.
Just to keep him company, he seemed to like that.
But it was from my point of view, pretty boring.
I'd sit in the car or go into the store while he took orders.
Of course, he'd have to stand around when the proprietor was waiting on customers because the customers were served first.
So there's a lot of waiting and watching.
I'm glad I wasn't in that business.
Did you have any siblings?
Yeah, I had a sister. She died about three or four years ago.
I heard child, of course, we moved his family.
I don't know nearly as much. She moved in a different group than I did.
She was two and a half years younger.
And so her high school group, the friends, or well-behind mind.
So we didn't have much of a social interaction as kids.
We just had different groups we were with all the time.
She went to Oregon State for a couple of years.
And then the work came along and she was a very good secretary.
And so she dropped out of school and served as a secretary to Naval Officer at the Naval Air Station in Astoria during the war.
And afterward, he set up a Ritter State business and so she went to California and served as the office manager for him.
And she married a young man from the area.
And so she lived most of her life in San Francisco, in the San Francisco area.
Actually, she retired over the...
I forgot what it's called, the tunnel from the Bay Area across into the valley.
Pleasanton.
What were your hobbies as a boy?
Well, in those days, we didn't have anything of the sort of thing they have now.
We had quite a lot of family interaction.
Evening, I remember when my father was home early enough and on weekends,
we played family cards like Rummy and Pinocchio and things like that.
The only source of entertainment, apart from the movies, was the radio.
And I can still remember my father and mother eagerly listening to certain programs in the radio,
among which were Amos and Andy.
You know, that, yeah, Amos and Andy, and a few of the other things.
And as for activity, I took up tennis when I was in Hoke and I played tennis all my life,
including on Medford High School team and on the OSU team when I came here later.
So that was a hobby.
And the other one was we had a lot of a group of pretty closely knit kids in the neighborhood
and we played a lot of football, touch football in the streets.
And that's mostly, oh, I collected stamps, but that was, you know, everybody collected stamps in those days.
And that's about, I guess I kind of summarized as what it was, no cell phones, nothing, no TV, nothing like that.
Do you recall being interested in science as a way?
I was always good in school, although I never really realized that I skipped a couple of grades.
During the, my real interest in science developed, well, I was always interested in it,
but it wasn't clear to me that I was going to be a scientist as a professional.
And through high school and so on science was always easy for me, both physics and chemistry.
And when I lived in Hoke, there were a number of people who always came to me with questions about science.
Excuse me, I didn't, we didn't have homework in the same way then, but it seemed to come so easily to me that I didn't
have much trouble answering the questions.
And then when I graduated from high school in Medford, it was on the height of the depression and my father had just lost his job.
And we were graduated in 1937 from Medford High School.
And there was no employment at all for young people.
There was some employment, which I avail myself of for several years.
I worked in the orchards, picking pairs, and so on and all again.
You did all this by hand.
And that's about the only income that I had.
There's nothing that a young high school guy with no specific skills,
or money at, I moved along here and there for 25 or 50 cents, that's about the going right then.
But I made good money in the orchards when I worked there.
It was very hard back-breaking, hopped, dusty work, but when you're young, that doesn't matter very much.
So back to your question, after I graduated, I began to wonder what I was going to do.
And I know I wanted to go to college and my parents, neither of whom had gone to college.
In fact, my father finished the eighth grade and my mother graduated from high school.
That was a limit of their education.
I always told me they wanted me to go to college and said that they would match every dollar I could earn.
Well, they personally put an end to that, of course.
So one day I went to the Medford Public Library.
I still remember when I walked in, I checked out a book in physics, elementary physics,
and another one in chemistry, and I took them home to read them.
The physics that was exposed in those textbooks of the day was pretty elementary,
stuff, mechanics, levers, and sort of thing.
The Manhattan Project, not radioactivity, that sort of thing was something that didn't penetrate
the high school level in the textbooks of the time.
So I finally decided I liked chemistry better.
And that started me on my career.
I managed to in 1939 in the winter of 39.
We were as my father, as I said, lost his job, and he was important living with his brother,
trying to land another job.
We had almost nothing in Medford, my mother and my sister and I,
and I was able occasionally to provide a little better money for groceries.
My father tried to send money, but at one point we were enough destitute,
so that the power kept me turned off all the electricity, and we cooked with a stove with some wood.
And we had a camping lantern, a coal and lantern that we used in the evening in the house.
We managed to avoid getting thrown out of the house, which is a rental in Medford, but just barely.
So for some reason, I'm not able to, at this day, remember how or why,
enough money was gotten together to allow me to register as Southern,
what was then called Southern Oregon Normal.
No, it's Southern Oregon University.
It's Southern Oregon State University, I guess, I don't know.
And for 10 cents a day, I had a friend of the car, I could pay him,
and I rode back and forth at him, stayed at home, and I registered for chemistry,
and a few other things, and took a number of courses in music.
And that continued, I got all these the first term.
My father told me, somebody in Portland had said,
you know, there was a guy, kind of headbridge, I noticed,
that all these Southern Oregon colleges, that's your son, my father knew nothing about this.
And I guess my mom didn't want to tell him that we had found money to send me to college,
but the tuition was a bag of tell, you know, something like $20 or $25 a term at that point.
So he said, no, that can't be my son.
When I turned all it was, he was not angry, he was delighted, actually.
So I stayed the second term, and I got all these except for one,
which is a B in piano, I had taken a number of courses in music,
and harmony, and composition, and things which interested me.
And at the end of that time, excuse me,
this is going to show up on your, you're going to have to edit out these throat clarings.
Well, at the end of that time, in the spring of 1939, my father actually got a job in Astoria,
and he and my mother decided that rather than she going to Astoria to join him,
she would move to Corvallos, and allow my sister and me to matriculate at Oregon State,
and she would set up a rooming house there, that rooming house would, we'd have three or four people,
staying with us, and she would do the cooking and so on,
and the rampant and things that she collected when enabled us to maintain a house,
so my sister and I could go to school.
That was done.
And at the time I didn't realize what a sacrifice that was,
but as time has gone on, I can see that was a monumental contribution on their part,
because I wouldn't have been able to go to Oregon State at all.
Excuse me.
Well, that was followed through, and I had one of scholarship tuition scholarship dollars use,
so I didn't have any tuition to pay, and then the National Youth Administration
was set up by Franklin Roosevelt, and this enabled students who qualified to earn 25 cents an hour,
and I got a job in the chemistry department here at Oregon State,
handing out supplies to people who were in the laboratories.
And that continued for 1941, a 40, and then late 1940,
my mother decided that we were now able to do this on our own,
and so she moved, we closed the house, and she moved to Astoria,
and I had pledged a fraternity, and so I had a place to live,
and my sister moved into a co-op that Oregon State.
And so I lived in my fraternity house for the rest of my career at OSU,
I finished in December of 1942.
Which fraternity were you in?
Tatekai.
It's still the same house, and in fact fraternity row there is not changed much at all.
I guess the houses have been renovated, but my social connections of the fraternity are essentially zero.
I have a lot of professional connections that I've spent my energy with.
What was your social experience like in college?
Oh, the social experience was tremendous.
My grandson is just mature, just enroled at
the hotel, thinking of the minimum.
He wrote back, he's a very studious guy, and it's superb,
he wrote back to my daughter that I was funny with having,
and she was greatly concerned that he wasn't studying.
He's just landed on the campus, well, I told her that was my experience at OSU.
I don't know how much is known about those days,
but there was a lot of social life, and the community was more strictly defined as,
as the independents, as they were called, and the Greeks, which concluded
all of the fraternity's priorities.
And there were lots of social functions associated with the university
on the students behalf that I don't see now, but that may be because
I'm a retired faculty member, but every Friday I think it was,
they had on the campus when I was a student, something called the Nickel Hops.
And this meant that all the sororities, in particular,
I'm not sure about the independence, but all the sororities,
cleared away the stuff on the living room, and they had
music that played, and men would move from one house to another,
and you paid a nickel to enter and dance with the girls that were there.
And so you'd go from one place to another.
So that was one way easy way of getting acquainted with girls.
The other important social affairs, or series of social affairs in the campus,
who are a bunch of formal dances, there was something called the sophomore
union, the junior prom, the senior ball,
and then something called the military ball.
It was put on by the oral chief secret of the piano and the campus.
And these were formal dances.
The women were long dresses, and the men were, on some occasions,
even took sedos.
But no less than a dark suit,
or these ties everywhere.
And they were events planned pretty much long in advance.
So you got yourself what was called a dance card,
and you went around to your friends, and the fraternity,
exchanged dances.
You came with your girlfriend, of course.
But you exchanged dances.
You didn't dance with her at the whole evening.
So you generally saved the last dance and the first dance
yourself on a couple in between, and then you would be
trading off with friends.
I don't know what happens these days, but I look back on that
with a good deal of fullness.
It was lots of fun.
The campus was highly regulated in the sense that
well, the put-on blunt terms it seems to me that the university
regarded itself and was looked at as a
defactal parent in the absence of a family, you see.
So there were real restrictions, particularly on the women.
If I remember this correctly, closing hours in all women's groups,
there were very few married students, very few on the campus.
I only knew one, one couple in chemistry.
So the students generally lived in living groups.
A few of them had apartments, but not very many.
And so these living groups, the women's living groups,
had strict closing hours.
The women had to be in by 930 on a school night.
That meant they were going to a library.
They were out of their living group at 7 o'clock in the
library.
And of course they could meet boyfriends and so on there.
Or you could arrange with your girlfriend a meter at one of
the Monroe Street places that sort of coaxed.
Have a coax or something like that.
But they had to be in by 930.
And if they weren't, if they were late,
they could be penalized by having their...
I'm forgotten.
Appendent penalties vary quite a lot, but they could be
campus which meant that they had to stay in their living group.
They weren't allowed to do certain things that they
otherwise would have been allowed to do.
The men had no restrictions on at all.
And in my house there was a real
strongly enforced study hours from 7 to 9.
The house was supposed to be very quiet and it was.
So I could name you
a flourish to those times.
That is studied.
The other thing I can come in on,
there was no alcohol available anywhere.
Not in town.
I think there was something like a two-mile rule.
There would be no retail outlet for alcohol
within two miles of the campus.
And that prevailed until
rather late in the history of the institution.
What you see along on our own street now is a lot of places
where you can get beer and other things in the students
or clearly enjoying their Fridays like today
at the Brew Station, for example.
But on those days you couldn't get it.
In fact, Oregon,
I forgot in what the date of the overturning of prohibition was,
but alcohol was slow to come to Oregon.
In the sense that, first of all,
you could only buy it in the green front.
You couldn't buy it in a restaurant.
But you could bring your bottle in a restaurant
and they would charge you a corkage fee
and serve you.
But that's a long time for that to be overturned.
So there's one incident that I can tell you about
that I mentioned it before, but it was really quite remarkable.
I think it was in the winter of 1941.
I think it was before Pearl Harbor.
When we had a tremendous ice storm,
I don't know whether you heard about this ice storm,
but what happened was we had a freezing rain.
And this was on the night of one of the old school dances,
which were held by the way in the Memorial Union Ballroom.
The size of the institution when I first in the fall,
maximum size was, I remember, 4,200 students.
So the MU Ballroom could generally contain all the people
that wanted to go to a formal dance.
A lot of people couldn't afford going, so they didn't.
Well anyway, in the MU on this particular occasion,
there was an ice storm that began early in the evening
and people began to show up.
And as the evening drew on,
the rain which had continued
began to develop into a freezing rain.
And the trees began to be branches began covered with ice.
All the power lines were covered with ice.
And as the dance went on, all of a sudden,
the maybe 839 o'clock, the lights went out.
And what had happened, of course,
is that the power lines were down because of the weight of the ice
and so on.
Well, this is an all-school dance and it was dark.
You see, no lights in the MU Ballroom.
So somebody scrounced up the candles
and put them around the edge or some other form of light.
But the MU lounge, which is very much the same as it is now,
is a place where, in these dances,
couples would repair, to rest a while and sit,
smooch with each other.
And when the lights went out,
she could imagine the glee that that was greeted with,
well, then after a show,
I happened to be up in the lounge at the time,
with my girlfriend at the time.
And the lights went out and,
and, due course,
there came one of the shopper-alls.
Usually a wife of a faculty member,
she came in with a large candle opera.
With lighted candles,
and she put it on a big table in the middle of the room.
And then she turned around and she walked,
and she walked back to the down the stairway down into the ballroom.
She got to the head of the stairs and disappeared.
One of the students there got up,
walked over to the candle,
and all the candles out to the great chairs.
And a few minutes,
the same woman came back,
and she lit the candles again.
And she turned around and walked away,
but she didn't get to the head of the stairs this time before the student,
maybe the same one went up and blew them out again.
Again, to great chairs,
this time she never returned.
And turned out,
the lights were out as a consequence of that storm
for the best part of a week.
And that was devastating,
it was extremely hard for my mother,
because we cooked on an electric stove.
And we had all these students there,
four of them plus my sister and myself.
So she prepared the meals
as best she could using pots and pans
and so on in the fireplace.
We had a fireplace fortunate,
and she could build a fire and do that.
So essentially we camp for a week,
remarkable experience,
well,
as far as the campus was concerned,
the consequences of that ice storm
were devastating.
The campus in front of the MU at the time
was covered in large numbers
of a large number of trees,
beautiful trees.
Perhaps many of them Elm trees,
I don't know.
The ice storm actually broke the branches
off of these trees to the point
where it looked like a tornado
and hit that section of the campus.
You could walk through it in the daytime
and it was still freezing.
You could still see the ice,
branches lying everywhere on their trees
effectively denuded
of their branches.
Well, I led to the removal of most of the trees
in front of the Memorial Union.
I suppose it was true
that this is only campus also.
I don't remember that,
but I certainly remember the MU before
and after remarkable thing.
So,
that's more or less the way
social life would say,
well, football, of course.
There were a couple of other things.
Football was mostly for the students
and a lot of them went.
But you weren't allowed to come with a girlfriend.
The men and women sat apart.
And if you walked in with a girlfriend,
there would be a raucous cheer
from the men's section,
and they would shout the word
Fusser, which was a...
and that term was a sort of a epithet.
There used to be
a director called the Fusser's Guide here,
and that was for people to look up the addresses
and film numbers and other students.
And there were...
some of the townspeople went to,
but the stadium would only hold a couple of thousand,
I think, maybe three thousand people
and just one grandstand along one side.
There's an install bleachers,
I don't remember that.
But there were also organized on the campus
four times a year,
it may have been six,
but certainly four,
what were called
Lycia,
Lycia in the singular.
And these were events
that comprised visiting artists of one kind
or another,
who often music.
And the...
I have heard
Harker Rubenstein play the piano here
for Oregon State at one of these.
I've heard Paul Robson sing
and a number of other people
like the really famous artists that would come.
And that was paid for,
I don't know how,
but home of university resources
because your student card admitted to these.
And they were held
in the old men's gymnasium
if I remember this correctly.
And with a small student body,
you always had enough space.
The...
I was going to...
I lost the thought of what I was thinking about
these Lycia,
but they were looked forward to
my a lot of people
and they, you know,
Oregon State students were
largely rural students.
Agriculture was the biggest college
on the campus
or school
and it was called.
And I guess this is regarded as an opportunity
to expose them at least
to a kind of a cultural side of life.
But they were quite remarkable events
and I was enthralled.
I didn't...
There's no history of music in my family
but I thought these were marvelous events.
So that was essentially
the way the campus was set up.
It was...
The old...
I was going to say the basketball games
were also played in the men's gym.
And the basketball schedule was different than
what it is now.
We have always called the Northern Division
and the Southern Division
and the Champions of these two
and meet for the Champions Coast Championship.
Let's see athletics sort of things there.
So what else can I tell you about the times?
Well, I'm interested also in
what your academic experience was as an undergraduate.
Oh.
Well.
After Southern Oregon
normal school
it was quite a change.
Now that...
The normal school is of course as you know
where teachers college is.
And so there was no major in science at all
and I just had elementary chemistry
by taught by a well-meaning lady
that really didn't know very much.
A couple years later one of my friends told me
that his brother was there on the same class as I was.
And this brother told my friend
that I knew more of the chemistry
than the teacher did.
I don't know whether that's true.
But at any rate
that gives you kind of a level of instruction there.
Well, when I came to us you
that was a different matter entirely.
And the first thing I took here
was a course in analytical chemistry.
And I was dismayed at my first grade
in an exam in that course
because by my Southern Oregon normal
standards it was a very difficult exam.
I didn't do very well on that.
I got to see or something like that.
But I wasn't used to that.
So I learned what I had to do
to work hard.
And I ended up with a B in that first term
for which I was very grateful.
And generally speaking,
I did very well here
after that initial shock.
And there was a lot of interaction
between faculty and students
because the classes were much smaller.
It was a good experience.
And I enjoyed it a lot.
Of course the war broke out
and I say I spent a year here
since I was in science.
I was deferred so I graduated.
And the campus was pervaded
by a sense of what was going to be happening
to almost everybody men on the campus.
So a lot of the students
chose paths that would take them
into the military offices training.
That sort of thing.
ROTC was required at that point.
I'm sorry I have to cough.
I have this just allergy
that comes this time of the year.
That's just about finishes my recollection
of my undergraduate days here.
Well as I say I played tennis
and we played Oregon,
again Washington State, Washington, Idaho,
and to get to these places.
We traveled by car.
And usually that was the car of our tennis coaches,
a guy named Bill McCallop who also played football here
and was on the faculty as a football coach
of some category or another.
So we drove, get to Idaho.
We drove a car.
You see, and then of course,
read a range to play Washington State at the same time.
So that was a long trip.
And by President standards,
a kind of uncomfortable car.
But we were young and there was lots of fun.
We're all at your chemistry classes in Gilbert Hall
or you didn't have classes in the age of chemistry.
All chemistry classes at that time were in Gilbert Hall.
There was a building down on Jefferson
and what is now 15th Street.
That used to be called a chem shock.
Len is pulling, of course,
met his wife in the chem shock.
And I've often walked him around the campus
on one time when we were walking down there.
He wanted to go into the building and we went up.
And we went on to the floor and he went into one of the rooms there.
And I can't remember whether the configuration was different from what he remembered, of course.
But he was able with reasonable certainty to identify the room
in which he was teaching when he met Eva Helen.
And he told me a couple of amusing incidents about the chem shock
in those days.
What did he say?
What did he say about the chem shock?
Well, there was one famous incident.
And you see, we didn't, I guess,
he didn't have natural gas as we did later on as when I was there.
And so when you had a burner in the laboratory,
this was generally burning gas, perhaps so subtly.
I think it was in a steel tank.
And that was mixed with oxygen and other Jason's tank.
And these were admitted into the laboratory by hoses.
And there was a guy there, an assistant of some kind,
and pulling told me his name, but it was a foreign name,
an Indian name or something like that.
A student who was working there and being paid to do certain things.
And he managed to get these lines connected up in the wrong order.
In such a way that when he turned on the tap,
the higher pressure in the oxygen tank forced its way through the tube
into the acetylene tank outside.
Well, the consequence of this ultimately for reasons
of the aeronics plane was an enormous explosion.
And fire that destroyed the stock room and much of the,
that section of what was called the chem shock.
And pulling said he never knew what happened to this student.
He wasn't hurt.
Nobody was hurt.
It turns out.
But pulling didn't know whether he had managed to get his degree or not.
That much he was able to tell me a while.
When I had read the chem shock, had a reputation for getting in the fire.
Had a reputation for getting in the fire?
Did it?
I don't know.
Well, this was certainly one.
And you can see why.
I thought was the method of firing up burners.
Chemistry nowadays has done in much more batches,
usually in the undergraduate labs and it was then.
I mean, if you made a preparation, then you made a pound of it.
I'm exaggerating.
But I mean, you had a lot of stuff there.
Nowadays, it's all green chemistry.
Very small amounts of things.
And the summertime, I worked once on the,
I think I don't remember whether I worked two summers or just one summer
and another vacation period on the campus as a part of the.
Oh, surveying crew.
And one of the guys who stayed with us and my mother's operated.
Rimming house was a guy who was a civil engineer.
And had a standing summer job.
And he ran this line of levels.
And so he taught me how to hold across things.
And so on taught me what the signals were and so on.
And that was better than working in the hot orchards in.
So they're Oregon.
But I didn't earn a lot more money out.
And I can say that.
I know the stalker I'm job that.
You signed up.
There were a number that was all student operated.
Well, there was a head of the stalker.
A man named Stony Wells.
I remember that still.
One of the reasons I remember it because I mentioned that name to my father.
And he said, Stony Wells, I know him.
So I brought him around one time.
And they shook hands and reminisced for a while.
I don't remember what the connection was.
But the students were the ones that actually did the legwork.
And taking in glassware, handing it out.
And those days you checked it out.
You had a pad.
And you filled out what it was you wanted.
And handed that to a guy behind a window,
just like other shelves someplace.
And he would go get the items and give them to you.
And then there was a return sheet.
And when he returned it, the items had to be clean and dry.
You put them back.
Looked at the sheet, made sure everything was there.
Put them back and then matched it up with the checkout sheet
and threw the two away.
So things were borrowed and returned from the stalker.
And we who did this work behind the window.
Or what we were being paid for by NRA.
And YAA, National Youth Administration.
The first year I got 25 cents an hour in the second year.
I got a raise to 30 cents an hour.
But that was big, big money in those days.
You could buy a Coca-Cola for a nickel.
And you could go to a movie or something like 25 cents.
And a full plate lunch would cost you 35 or 40 cents.
Something like that.
I remember my childhood, and hopefully on my father,
and my mother was away.
And my father and I went out to a local rooming house.
It was called a finished boarding house in Hokewim.
And they would serve meals to people.
It came in.
It was family style.
A big long table.
A bunch of silent guys sitting there and spooning it in.
And the cost of that for the two of us was something for each of us.
Something like 20 cents a piece.
Just a bag of tell about today's standards.
Unbelievable.
Were there any classes or teachers that made a big impact on you?
Oh, yes. There were.
JP Maelig was a very long-term faculty member here.
He was an analytical chemist.
The first man that I really met on the faculty,
because that's the first course I had to enroll in here.
He lived to be over 100 years old.
And he was a man of incredible precision.
Everything he did, his whole analytical chemist,
seems to fit his personality.
Because he did everything by the clock and by rules.
People used to say, JP Maelig always walked to work.
And he lived down on eight streets or something like that.
And he would walk up Jefferson to the chem shack.
And I was told, I don't think the story is apocryphal,
but maybe the, I mean, people used to stand and wait for
Maelig to walk through the gates.
And they said you could almost literally such a watch by his coming in.
Well, I had a little, he got his degree at Purdue.
And he never ceased to be very interested in what Purdue was doing.
And he subscribed all his life to the student daily newspaper.
He used to go back there for the summers to do research.
And he drove his car.
And every year he changed, he bought two new tires.
Either for the front or the back and older not years.
And those days tires in land nearly is, in the last nearly as long.
And then the work came along.
They couldn't get tires and he was terribly upset.
It turned his life around on an uncomfortable way
because he was so used to buying these tires.
There was another man later, made a great impression on me.
And that was a man named James W. Ferguson.
He was an organic chemist.
And as a war broke out, of course, he left.
And he went back and worked for the Midwest for Eli Lilly Company.
But anyway, his high-learned and enormous amount of organic chemistry
from him, he didn't do a lot of research.
But he was certainly a support teacher from my point of view.
Another person, of course, was Bert Christensen,
who became department chairman after I returned to the faculty.
He was remarkable in a way because as a faculty member,
because it was very hard to do research here at the time.
Federal grants didn't exist down.
The kind of structure we have now, like National Science Foundation, didn't exist.
So you had to do everything more or less on your own,
and you got very little contribution if any from the state.
But he managed to involve himself and research both with graduate students
and undergraduates.
And I worked for him for a year or so,
and a very interesting project that we finally published.
And that was my first publication with Bert Christensen.
There was another guy named Bill Caldwell.
I never had his a teacher, but he was a very popular instructor of freshman chemistry.
I had very fancy demonstrations that the kids liked a lot.
And then of course, there was E.C. Gilbert, who was a physical chemist.
But I grew to know all these people as a student,
but of course, when I came back in the faculty,
all alone, once I mentioned it, except Ferguson, or still here.
Ferguson, after he went back to Eli Lilly,
he returned to Oregon and he went to Portland State,
where he finished his career there.
And after I came back in the faculty here,
I saw him a few times in Portland.
He looked just the same.
So those, of course, I knew other faculty members too,
but I didn't have them in any of the coursework that I took.
So there's a project that you did with Bert Christensen.
That was your first experience of scientific research.
Well, it was called, are you asking, what kind of work it was?
Yes, and that was your first research project.
Yeah, well, it was called a micro-determination of hydroxyl group.
And it was an analytical technique where you worked with very small amounts of sample using
hydrobalances, sealed them up, and then a reaction took place.
And then we could analyze the mixture and we could determine one aspect of the composition of a molecule.
Later on, when I worked at Shell Development Company, I learned that our analytical method
was being used in that commercial analytical lab.
So that was really pleasing to me that they were big time down there.
So by the time you were done with an OSU, and you decided that you wanted to be an academic?
No, the war was on them.
And I was faced with a decision about what I was going to do.
And I had two opportunities.
The war work was going on in the chemical industry.
And in particular, there were people from Shell Development Company who came around,
and they were looking for people who recommended by the faculty to do war work on some of their projects.
The other opportunity, and I was interviewed by them and offered a job.
The other opportunity was to go into the Air Force in a program that would have been,
for me, and meteorology, or an armament, not in flying, because at the time, my visual acuity wasn't very good.
And so I had been registered with a draft board, and I went to see Gilbert.
And Gilbert, he was a nice guy, I liked him a lot.
But he kind of grumbled, or, you know, he would talk in a little voice.
He said, I think it's ridiculous for you to go into the Air Force.
And not use your chemical training when you could do that.
In war work, for they need skilled people.
And so then I went down to my draft board, and I talked to the chairman of a draft board.
And I think his name was Cindy McCollum, or something like that.
I thought he was clearly a scot.
And he ran a gas station down town.
And I explained this situation to him.
And you said, young man, you better go in the Air Force, or we're going to draft you.
Well, this calls me to think a little bit about this.
And at that point, I knew I wanted to go to graduate school, you see.
To make a long story short, I finally decided that I would take the job at Shell Development Company,
which was a professionally extraordinarily valuable experience.
But in terms of emotional contentment, it certainly wasn't very relaxing.
First of all, I spent most of the war on one A, which is the draft status eligible for a draft.
And you never know whether you're going to be drafted.
And well, I guess I shouldn't have said it that way.
When you're in one A, you're eligible to be drafted, and will be drafted.
So, I was always classified one A by the draft board.
The company appealed to the appeal board at Oregon on grounds, and I was doing war work and supplied the paper.
There are a vacation of this, and because of the secretive and important nature of this war work,
I was always reclassified in different stages of to be.
Now, this deferred status lasted for only six months, dated from the time that you were first classified one A.
Well, it took about three months for this process to go on, and for you to be reclassified to be, but by that time you only had three months left.
So, I spent literally half of the entire war years in one A while the process of keeping me deferred to do this war work went on.
And it's more than just paperwork, because before you're classified one A, you get a notice on the draft board that says greetings.
And then you have to appear for a physical.
Well, they would tell you when you first of all, I had to appear at fifth and one rule for a physical.
So, I can't do that. I mean, we're engaged in war work down here.
We'll transfer your physical down there all this took time, you see.
So, then I would take the physical, or I would go down.
I'd be transported to San Francisco after the procedure.
And there are a whole bunch of potential draftes were lined up, and we went through a physical, it took at least.
Well, it took all morning, and the most of the afternoon.
A which time?
You either classified as physically capable or classified four F, which means incapable of military service.
So, at the end of this, I was classified one A. My draft board was notified, and they told me I was one A.
Then the company would get the papers, and they would appeal this, and we would go through the whole thing again.
I did that about five times, I think, during the war.
And on one occasion, just before the war was ending both in the Pacific, both in the European theatre,
was in 1945, and I had an emergency appendectomy, and those days an emergency appendectomy was a big deal.
I was in the hospital in Oakland for over a week, bedridden. They didn't allow you to get up or anything.
I had a huge scar like this long there.
So anyway, in the middle of all this, my notice to appear for a physical part.
But I knew that if you had a recent serious operation, and that was serious in those days, you're automatically deferred for six months.
So, I tried to tell them that I'd add a recent appendectomy, so take your physical.
So, I lined up down in Oakland, and we didn't do course or transport it across the bay with a hundred other guys.
You see, I'm told a strip there, and I said to the courseman, and the first courseman, I said,
I said, I've had a recent appendectomy, and I said, I'm supposed to be deferred for six. He says, get in line.
I got in line. I came to the next courseman, I said the same thing to him, he said, get in line.
Went through all the tests and so on and passed them all, and came to the last guy who was an officer there, and there's a guy who was supposed to test for their mentally fifties as psychologists.
And he looked me up and down and said, you had a recent appendectomy, and I said, yes, I've been trying to tell him that all day long. He grabs my papers and he writes deferred.
And lastly, the war ended, there was still going to be occupation forces, and the war ended, of course, in the Pacific and August of 1945.
And a lot of the military were being decommissioned and sent home and so on.
And then the year were rolled around and the question was, who were they going to have in the occupation forces?
And at this point, of course, there was no further need of my services than this war work, and so I was eligible for this.
But on the second of February in 1946, I turned 26, and they didn't take anybody over 25.
So then I was automatically out of the occupation draft group, and then I entered Caltech in the spring of that year, left Sheldon Elementary Company.
Well, there were several things. The Japanese, of course, had succeeded in overrunning all of the plantation that provided latex for natural rubber, which is of course really needed during the war.
And so synthetic rubber had been discovered, and there were all sorts of ways of making synthetic rubber. So I worked a lot on the problem of synthetic rubber.
Another thing that developed about this time during the war was the discovery of the efficacy of penicillin, which is being produced in a traditional way.
In our area, by cutter laboratories, it existed in either in Emoryville or in Berkeley or Oakland, right down there close to the bay. They had huge vats, and they cultivated this and separated the penicillin, which was distributed to the armed forces, was not available to civilians at all.
At this time, and I worked on the extraction, the methods for extracting penicillin from this.
The third thing that I did was that was probably the most interesting, in many ways, was an aviation gasoline inhibitor.
Now, aviation gasoline, in that time, was hundred octane fuel, because all the aircraft were propeller driven, and there was a high performance engines that required that level of anonaut quality.
This was particularly during the North African campaign, and these tanks of hundred octane fuel were shipped across, and then they had to stand in the desert.
Now, one thing that happens to gasoline is that over time, they tend to form some gum, which settles out to the bottom.
Now, that gum, if it gets into the engines, of course, can be a very serious matter.
So, they apply what are called inhibitors to delay or greatly slow down the formation of this gum.
And the stockpiles of fuel there in North Africa had in them a die, a red die.
It turned out that when the gum was formed, this red die would be a clue to take down the fuel with changed color.
So, the sergeants running the dump would realize what it was going on, and they would then use this deteriorated fuel and jeeps, and then motor vehicles of various kinds.
Well, of course, it's obvious that what you want to do is to prevent this from happening as long as possible, because that's expensive fuel to be using in jeeps.
Then it turns out that a lot of the time that the stuff was gone, the die was disappearing, the fuel was still good.
Well, we had a special inhibitor that was better than anything in use that we were developing and testing in the desert with a drum, that we have mounted on the demahave desert at an army base with a bunch of thermocouples all through it, because we needed to figure out, we needed to figure out how quickly the gum formed,
in accordance with weather conditions. I mean, if you store these drums I mentioned in North Africa and the winter there's no problem it's cold, and in the summer it goes to pot very quickly.
Well, how do you know that because you don't know what the temperature inside the fuel is, because in the summer a barrel at the bottom might be relatively cool and one at the top would be totally gone.
We had a way, we put these thermocouples all through this test drum, and then we could measure the rate of formation of gum as a function of, well, we took these temperature data from the thermocouples all through the drum and worked that up into something that we could call an effective temperature for the whole drum.
And we could predict from a thermocouple in any place what the effective temperature was in the whole drum.
And that would tell us how long that fuel could be expected to last, and so we did that in addition to developing and testing our inhibitor which turned out to be very good.
Well, the war ended before the inhibitor could actually be used, and then of course the fuel now is not under octane anymore, so that never got into production, but if the war gone on much longer it would have been.
That's the kind of thing that I did, and all of this laboratory work was of tremendous aid to me when I entered graduate school because I know how to use my hands, I've been doing it for three years in the laboratory.
This job was in Southern California.
Yeah, Caltech.
Oh, is that Caltech?
I went to Caltech.
Oh, the shell was it, it was an Emoryville.
It was called shell development.
Emoryville is a small on-play between Berkeley and Oklahoma on the Bay.
Well, we're at about an hour and 10 minutes.
Do you want to keep going or do you want to?
Well, I can go a longer.
I probably should leave here about quarter to twelve, and if you want to.
Okay.
Or we can do whatever you like.
Well, if you're, if you're, if you're, if you're left, if I'd like to keep going.
So, you finished up at shell, and then you went to Caltech.
How did, what was the process by which that happened?
How did you mind at the Caltech?
Well, the laboratory work,
and it's shell.
I should say just a little bit more about that.
Was a small laboratory.
You know, a shell development.
There were all sorts of projects distributed all over.
There was a motor lab out and back, in which gasoline's were tested.
I was in the research end, and there were,
where the head of my small laboratory,
and another guy who had been working there for a long time,
and I was brought in as a third guy to help these people.
We became all three of us, very close friends,
and as social as well as in a professional sense.
The man who, who headed as a name,
Daniel B. Luther Jr.
And he was a remarkable person.
He was a very good scientist.
And at the same time, when the war was over, during the war,
he got very interested, partly because of this North African stuff.
In climate, and thereby associated himself with geography.
So he knew a great deal about geography all over the world,
and especially about climate changes in temperature and so on.
And he used to amuse us by coming up with some facts that you know that you didn't know.
He said, where do you think the rainyest July in the world is?
Where is the place where the rainyest July takes place?
Well, right away, you think monsoon or something.
It turns out there is some village called Charapunji India,
and India, and he said in the monsoon season,
he announced to us that it had something like 240 inches of rain in the month of July.
These are the kind of facts that he would come up with.
Well, the reason I mentioned all this is that after the war was over,
he retired from shell as a chemist,
but became so knowledgeable in this other area
and he was appointed an adjunct professor of geography at Cal.
And as time went on, he built quite a reputation in that field.
He came to Oregon State, gave lectures here, was invited up on the geography department.
He was a very, very interesting guy.
The other fellow is Joseph's interesting.
His name was Aldo, the Benedictus, and he was an Italian, obviously.
He came from an Italian family.
He was engaged to the head of business and making pasta.
And one time he told me, he says, don't let him kid you.
He says the dough is all the same.
It's just the die that makes the difference between pasta.
So the texture is different depending on the die, but not the dough.
Well, Benny graduated from Cal.
He was an excellent student, but he had a family of several children,
and he had to go to work.
But not having a doctor's degree, he was not running the lab, you see.
But Dan Luton treated him in every way as an equal.
He had his own projects and everything.
Well, he spoke Italian fluently.
And Shell had a occasion to want somebody that knew Italian very well
to serve as a translator and so on.
And after the war, he moved out of chemistry into marketing for Shell,
where his language skills could be useful and he moved to New York.
Well, he did very well in the company.
He moved up the ranks, finally when he retired officially from that aspect of Shell,
they moved back to Berkeley, he and his wife and family.
Guess his kids were grown and they lived there at the time.
And then he told me he became very wealthy after he retired.
And he told me how this happened.
There is a company knowing as...
I'm thinking advanced micro-devices.
It's not that one.
It's another one that makes chips.
It's the biggest chip maker in the world now.
Chips for computers and so on.
Pardon?
No, no.
No, they make...
Well, I'm sorry, I'm a spoke.
I think they make the devices for making chips.
But he told me, many told me, we told him, many.
That he was approached by some people about this project.
And he said about five or six of them sat down
around the kitchen table in his house in Berkeley.
And he decided he... they all put up $10,000.
And that company just grew like wildfire
and he ended a multi-millionaire just by just thinking that money.
And so he endowed a chair at Berkeley in chemistry,
called the All of the Benedictus Chair of Chemistry.
His wife went to UCLA and was an nutritionist.
And he set up a similar thing in her name at UCLA
with another million dollars.
So this was done years ago.
It must be worth a lot more than that now.
So I thought that was quite a remarkable story for a guy
who spent his youth making pasta and working
in a chemistry laboratory to end up like that.
Okay, so Caltech, what decided me to go there?
Well, I was thinking about going there
and I wrote that you see Gilbert and he said, well,
you have to.
You said, you know, there's a very good university right there
where you're working.
That's the University of California.
For some reason, I wasn't interested in going to Cal.
I don't know why.
But it's a tremendous institution.
Of course, some great people there.
But maybe I don't know nothing about that area for the while.
And so I applied to Harvard and to Caltech.
And in due course, I was admitted to both of these as a student
and then I had to make a decision.
And so I talked to Dan Looton about all of this and he said, well,
I said, Caltech has got Linus Pauling.
Who else do they have on the staff?
And I knew a lot of people that Harvard, you know,
are very famous people.
But the only one I knew at Caltech was Linus Pauling.
And Looton with his customary bruskin since a human manner
he says, look, he says, with Linus Pauling,
they don't need anybody else.
That was his famous line to me.
And I've never forgotten that well.
That wasn't enough to decide me.
But what did decide me was that it was only a short distance away.
It was on the West Coast and a place which at that time
was reputed to be beautiful as indeed it was.
And I had a small beat up car that I knew wouldn't make it
across the United States.
And so I packed this thing up with my dogs, my wife and myself,
and we started out for Caltech.
And I'll tell you this, too.
This is more a personal history than it is a professional history.
I guess maybe.
That's all right.
Well, this was a 1933 Chevrolet coupe.
And it had been repaired once.
And I started out.
We had it loaded my wife and myself and we started up a steep hill
out in the valley just before you get into Southern California.
And the car began to falter.
And then it wouldn't go any more.
But then if I stopped it, fired up the engine,
it would catch and I could go a short distance and go,
it would stop.
Just as if it were tired, you see.
So then I turned the thing around and managed to get over to the other land.
I wasn't a freeway on those days.
And I went down at the bottom of the hill.
The car ran just fine.
Pulled it up into a gas station, which was closed for the evening.
And it had mechanic.
I saw seated with it.
And so I pulled into this gas station.
There was a light on in the house and back.
And I asked about mechanic.
I came to the door and said, well, line on mechanic.
And I said, well, I hate to bother.
I guess you're closed.
This is what your problem.
I explained this to him.
And he put down his knife and fork.
You're literally having dinner.
And he went out and he listened to this and looked.
He says, you need to know a fuel pump.
He says, I don't have one here.
But I think I know where I can get one.
And so I said, gee, that's very kind to you.
And he said, no, no, that's okay.
And he gets in his car and he goes away.
He's a team and later.
So he appears and he's got the fuel pump.
And then he gets to work on my car and puts the new fuel pump in.
And those days it was a fairly simple job.
Put the new fuel pump in.
We fired it up and he says, there.
Now I want to do it.
And I said, how much do I owe you?
He says, well, he says, you pay me for the fuel pump.
And I said, I got to give you more than that.
He says, no, no.
I says, sometimes you just have to help a guy out.
That is a lesson.
You know, that happened when I was 26 years old.
I have never forgotten about.
And to my last angry grat, I never learned the guy's name or the location of this.
But I have never forgotten that.
Absolutely remarkable.
You know, I spent a lot of time.
And he wanted nothing for his time.
So I didn't know that you were married at this point.
Yeah.
But that was my first wife.
We divorced some years later.
And my second wife was met a Norway.
And we've been married for 55, 56 years of something.
Anyway, they get back to Teltaq.
So I don't know where the hill got down.
I found a place by then-wife relative.
They were offered to put us up for the night to not her husband was a postman in Pasadena.
And he, on his realms, happened new quite a bit about vacancies and so on, which were very, very few.
And in that time, in that area, there were a lot of houses that had garden colleges and back to them.
And he knew about one of these.
And I went up to my wife and I went up interview these people.
There were old people, 80 years old or so.
And nobody was in the house.
And they had fixed it all up.
They were very particular about their tenants.
And after I just, we turned on the charm, but they agreed finally to run it to us.
And we were then able to wheel up our few belongings and put them in the house, which was furnished.
And we lived there for quite a long time.
When I went to Teltaq, I presented myself at the main office.
And I set up on appointments.
Mrs. Wolf, Beatrice Wolf, who was his secretary.
She said, well, Dr. Pauling likes to talk to all the new graduate students.
I'll set up on appointment for you.
And she did.
I can't remember whether I got an office right away or not.
But then you might do remember the interview with Pauling.
He knew that I was from Oregon and from Oregon State.
And of course, there was a kind of a bomb there because he had gone to.
I mean, not a bomb, but at least there was something in common.
And so he asked me, well, I was interested in it.
I told him I was interested in chemical kinetics and mechanisms and so on.
And he said, well, he said, it's too bad because the right person for you to work with would have been Roscoe Dickinson.
But he died last year of cancer and we haven't anyone to take his place yet.
But he said, we do have a young postdoctoral fellow here from back east.
And he's interested in this kind of work and doing a project.
And it would be fine for you to work with him if you would like to.
And he would like to have you.
And to this day, my mind is boggled at that because you can't imagine our department chairman here.
Suggesting that any of the incoming graduate students that work with a postdoc and not with a faculty member is hands are very hard to come by and research program.
So I went to see this man whose name was Seaguardner Swain, who later went on to a distinguished career at MIT as an organic chemist.
And I worked a full year for him until his period was over.
And we did a project, a project of his, it turned out just fine.
And we published a paper on it together.
It was a, it was the oxidation of a lucho malachite green to malachite green carbonyl was an organic compound, which then decomposed or, yes, to form a die called malachite green.
And we could study the reaction by watching the color formation of this stuff.
So it was a fine project and it was good for me because it was good for Gardner because I had all this laboratory experience during the war.
Probably had more than he had at that time in the actual laboratory work.
But he was a very clever guy and if we wanted to do a reaction at Shell Development Company, we had all the equipment on the shelf there.
I could bring down a, what was called a thermostat, a constant temperature bath.
I could put up the control mechanism called, and put in the controlling thermometer and the heaters and so on.
I would have it all set up in 15 or 20 minutes.
At Shell Tech, they didn't have any such thing.
So Gardner sat down, he was good at electronics and he drew out some components, so he would need.
And I went up to the avenue to an electronics store and bought these things, came back and spent, I don't know, how long.
A couple of weeks or three, maybe even more than that, to the taking courses, building is relay that would work, building it, putting it together, soldering wires and so on.
And then I spent another week locating and getting transported a big tank, which I could fill with water,
sold our samples.
I set up the heater and put everything in it and got it going.
It took me the best part of six months versus that 20 minutes I mentioned.
Once it was set up, reactions, experiments when rather nicely and conveniently fast.
That got done and Gardner's year there.
That was a good experience, so at the end of that time, I had to decide I was looking ahead.
What else I was going to do?
And there was a young guy there, he's only about six years older than I was.
That had a very, very, very good scientist.
He'd done his work with Pauling and banana to the faculty.
And he had a group of young people who were kind of eager, and I went to talk to him.
And the help showed of that conversation as I decided to work with him.
And we had a project that we settled on right there.
So Gardner left.
I began to work with this man whose name was Werner Schumacher.
So maybe we should talk about some of this at a later time.
So I can do that.
Well, I can do is send you, and eat well.
Why don't you send me an email suggesting sometimes?
Because I think I can fit more easily than you.
Now next week, I'm going to be in Ashland.
Going Tuesday and won't be back to the weekend.
Is that okay?
The week following that, we can do.
Let's see.
We're looking into October now, Tros.
No, we're not.
After the Ashland week, I'm free.
Every day except Thursday when the president is hosting a marriages faculty.
That'll luncheon.
So Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday and Friday are all available.
Okay.
And the next week is entirely free.
That's the week beginning the 26th.
We do it Thursday and then the week after the week.
Okay.